hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to reject now if you
remember this animation made way back in
the day called animator versus animated
it was about this animation that this
person was drawing and it came to life
and started attacking and destroying the
desktop of the animator if you haven't
seen it I'll put in the description I
guarantee you have a great time watching
it but this one is kinda in the same
vein it's not made by the same person
but the idea is a little bit similar so
this one's kind of like that but not
entirely all right back to work
now I can do better than that what kind
you whoa wait a minute you can move I
did play a little bit of this so I know
what's going on let's make you oh let's
make you look better I think is what I
was supposed to be saying there ah
yes nice and inked I'm permanent now you
couldn't have put some more muscle on me
maybe some facial descriptions I'm kind
of a Slender Man esque guy standing here
so no wonder I Rebell here take this you
better find out how to use it yeah the
the best thing to first give your
creation is a weapon to kill I mean I'm
sure that's that that's a wonderful
lesson to set for everybody all right
here come more because apparently this
guy is an evil deity and only wants to
see his creations suffer and die I mean
if you think about it the morality of
this is a little bit questionable
but I'm not gonna ask too much out of it
so it's a top-down style shooter if I
can just state the obvious for everybody
that has eyeballs and obviously you
could tell of them Sir George that's
kind of commentary quality that I have
these days I don't really know else what
I did you do beside blam-blam-blam- and
make sound effects with my mail maybe
move everything out BIM BAM boom BAM
baby Bobby baby book me Babu meet Booga
Babu
I don't think headshots do anything
you'll need something bigger for the
next fight oh thanks for a no it's
another gun I thought maybe you would
have taken my criticism to heart and
giving me something bigger
cuz I'm pretty sure right now I'm like a
Ken doll and you know we drawings have
needs besides murder
don't know if you knew about that but
bla I'll murder anyway so thank you for
uh thank you for being so attentive to
me and teaching me that violence is the
only answer in this cruel and
unforgiving world that is the lesson
that I'm supposed to get out of this
right like I'm not supposed to
understand love or or peace or or you
know anything like that
are you are you eventually gonna draw me
you know like a companion or we doing an
Adam and Eve kind of thing here or is it
just is it's just murder isn't it
because all these creatures I mean you
know I I don't want to love them cuz he
kind of made them a little bit hideous
and horrifying but you know how whatever
murders good enough about big boo-boo
baby the movie can we do boo-boo
all those slimes can take a lot of
bullets okay we're past the point where
I played it before so why do what's
going on happy to be able to be me oh no
he was just born and now he's dog skis
hello oh it's a fireball shooter
oh boy I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a
pink eye in that your gut you're gonna
die I don't know some guy that's the
best your oh my coins
Jesus fireballs hurt okay so don't get
cornered take care of these guys or I
guess I can hit him from range at Ababa
why is there no friendly fire looks like
you made it thanks man
checkpoint reached hell yeah Oh God well
I'm not gonna make it now a bit about a
bit about me to be able to Bobby to be a
bit about I'd like to think that
everything's first feeling should be
horrifying excruciating pain I mean what
I'm wondering is how this guy drew these
things with an imbued sense to kill you
know that that murderous instinct that I
of course was imbued with because that's
all I know
or maybe it's a quest for survival but
you know even so like they're doing the
same thing
oh yeah what is that I don't like that
oh that's horrifying oh why did they
giggle when they died maybe they just
wanted to give me a hug maybe it was a
love trunk tree trunk love tree trunk
tree trunk of love I need to kill this
thing
quickly oh why do they need to giggle
I'm pretty sure I'm killing babies here
and that's something that I didn't think
that I would say out loud on my channel
you know don't you die just yet
oh but everything else that's that's
totally fine okay all right I understand
maybe they hear to be pity baby to be
the baby oh geez Oh what is that I don't
want to know what that is it's got two
eyes and wrong you dare oh don't you
groan at me
I'll outgrow anyone any day all right
goodbye eyeballs last wave forever and
then you're sure I'm gonna I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be allowed to leave I'm gonna
Balad to pursue happiness I mean if you
guys were suddenly drawing one day and
you managed to create life like what
would you do with oh I'm cornered right
now that I River the girls drunk that
trunk is evil too even though it's a
mother it deserved
oh god it's mom or I'm a women get
buh-buh-buh-buh
still alive huh yeah what are you trying
to kill me
cuz that's no good bro here's a present
for you oh are you gonna take away my
gun oh I don't know if I wanna take it
okay what is that okay I think sorry I
got text yeah what I don't know what you
said I looked away for a second here's
another one here's another one oh hey I
knew it was a trick I had a funny
feeling did you just make a bunch of
people now oh no no no oh no oh geez oh
geez oh geez
that's a lot of whatever those are is
that are they rednecks waving guns are
they just trying to clean up with brooms
I'll oh my god I have a funny feeling
that they're just rata they're just
trying to clean up oh that's not good
get out of my face oh not gonna make
this I'm not gonna make it I'm gonna
make I'm not gonna be oh I might make it
okay yeah the problem was they spawned
all around the inside and they just
swarmed around me soon these guys aren't
bad literally look at this guy he he's
just trying to sweep with a broom he's
just trying to clean up and he's saying
good day sir good day m'lady oh no that
was silly yeah a little bit acting
normal stuff I don't know if that's okay
at least they got a checkpoint blam blam
okay I like this better feels good Oh
only one shot for the for that for the
Skelos and bid there boo boo baby and
you're dead as well okay so everybody's
dead now all there's more okay of course
there's more why wouldn't you I mean
it's like an addiction this guy has I
mean III don't know girl I have no idea
but it's an addiction this person has
whoever's drawing all this crap
oh these babies don't stand a chance up
against a shotgun get rid of that thing
gotta get rid of you oh you just burned
but now we must do oh [ __ ] I didn't even
see that thing up there gotta kill that
nope oh that's not good that was down oh
boy
I don't see him putting these things
down so like the babies are sneaking up
on me
that guy's ripped it up he just came in
to see hey guys what's going on
Oh okay now everyone's dead now can I
get a check oh god not another one if I
take even one hit of damage I'm dead
you're gone you don't you don't ya ever
everybody look I didn't even see them
traversing the distance towards me I'm
an idiot
god damn it oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no get out of my way okay give me a
goddamn checkpoint give me a checkpoint
Hey ink war machine yeah that's me
meet your final challenge you better
give me a checkpoint though okay good
final challenge indeed maybe whoo that
looks interesting oh it's it's it all
that's lovely
congratulations you really reach the
peak level of your imagination I hope
your boss walks in on you and sees the
wanton murder that you're unleashing on
a poor
new life-form oh god boy pink balls oh
no can't hit me can't hit me I'm so
mobile so this one's just if I stay
moving if I keep moving I should be whoa
reached here okay so I gotta watch where
they're spawning in front of me to
butter than that it doesn't seem to be
doing much damage ah school you shoot
okay you missed me you douche yeah yeah
yeah yeah how's it feel
how's it feel down bullets in your
dinner plate eyes sure is a lot of holes
in the ground there's gonna be last one
oh geez oh geez oh geez now you're
getting a little too slappy buddy you're
getting way too slappy I don't like when
people get too slap-happy I mean I'm one
to talk cuz I got literally guns Oh your
dad
and look I just wanted to give me a
handshake or a nice pat on the rump as I
was going along he was like good work
out there slugger
Wow you have done it good work I can
draw you something for you as a reward
what will it be a woman yeah what I
didn't say any hear me oh whoa
better have been a nice peaceful ending
thank you for playing well what did I
get
what was my reward they made by grouille
grouille was my reward you put me
through endless suffering how many lives
have I taken the moment I was created
and yet you put me towards wanton murder
am I not a man do I not think do I not
feel do I not have emotions and do I not
need love probably not I'm just drawing
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching you can play this for
yourself down in the description below
it's really fun yeah I know about lame
ending of this game oh do you grouille
oh do you hope you liked it anyway at
least you got a good attitude about it
so it was a pretty good game also the
name reject reminds me of that other
animation that was like hey everyone
knows rejected like the long animation
mas une is too big
I'll put that in the description too huh
I'll put a whole smorgasbord of stuff
down in the description so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you bye
[Music]